so what is it like to be part of such a
large ensemble and getting together
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
large ensemble it's great coming into it
seeing this whole family just interact
with each other and when they were very
welcoming for me so that was that was
quite nice yeah
Chrissy all right you know what signing
up to a movie like this one you know you
have to make you know consider you have
to keep coming back you don't really
know what you're signing up for so you
don't know everybody involved yet and
and to kind of be dealt this lucky hand
of everyone's being just jams is really
just an embarrassment of riches you've
been a part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe for a long time and your fan
experience do you have a good experience
with the fans that you've truly been
it's it's been the thing that makes this
I mean this sounds cheesy that makes
this all worth it you know when you when
you're making these movies you have them
in mind because you know how much it
means to them because I know how much
movies meant to me when I was younger
especially things that involve trilogies
and the the Mark said earlier the
dedication that's really like the best
word to describe it they're they're so
committed and it's it's this kind of
built in anticipation and built-in hype
and and it's it makes every day on set
exciting because if you're excited about
something they're gonna be excited about
something and that that that's what
makes this so satisfying you can't walk
around feeling bad for very long when
someone's like runs up oh my god
so you played Bruce Banner over and I
did a few that over and over about two I
mean obviously is a very complex guy he
he's you know if going back to to these
backstory and all the in the comics he's
you know he's got a heavy he comes from
a heavy background and uh you know he's
got it he's got to work it out he has to
really work it out and he does you know
he he he gets to where he needs to be
marked yeah similar character sorry um
my favorite part playing nebula and I
think it's just sort of trying to make
this villain empathetic and trying to I
basically sort of feel like her lawyer
where I'm like no she was totally
justified here's why I've been hopefully
trying to get the audience to sort of
and understand her a little bit more and
I think that's probably a good message
for the world tried to understand your
enemies you know so you play Thor over
the Cinematic Universe many many times
what was exciting about playing this
version the floor in endgame well it was
each time I've always wanted to do
something different and thor ragnarok
was for me the biggest sort of shift
tunnel II and I came into Infinity Ward
and he was talking to you know the
directors and said look I really want to
continue with this newer version I've
created and they said no no we've got
any
new aversion and that was what I've
really appreciated in infinity war and
in this one again and I wish I can tell
you about what that is no it's some
super cool stuff I can't wait for people
to see other stuff and Captain Marvel
just made her debut and made her mark in
the Cinematic Universe how was it to be
playing with the Avengers I don't know
who don't even know what my point is in
this movie at all I might just stop in
for a quick set I'm gonna leave
understand when you pause over to the
trailer that's right that's in the
trailer of course that you said that was
your hard-luck you did say the highlight
I felt like it was difficult
that day I know just like relax so I'm
just a world it's just Chris it's just
Chris I'm just someone destroy this was
like I think of it as some time when I
was like getting you know all around
just trying to get sea legs and done
you've been in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe a--'s for a long time what is
your favorite part about playing war
machine oh I just say legs why did you
do that before my question
tired team me up for something no this
has been a very interesting ride and a
lot of fun and a lot of growth that
these characters have and and and still
to be this many movies in and to still
be changing they still have new stuff to
do it's just been really exciting so
both of your characters were off doing
other things during infinity Wars so how
does it feel to be back in the fight we
don't fight we get along famously in
fact the reason we weren't even in and
we went on we went we went on a
ping-pong tour across your us right we
were visiting France yeah we had swim
lessons together right it was a really
great time it was a fun summer and then
we got back and found out everything
that had happened that's right
thankfully we avoided it that's right
well okay Jeremy your character Hawkeye
has a close relationship with Black
Widow how did it feel as an actor to get
back in the groove with working with
Scarlett hey with I anything expended
with everybody the best part of this
this movie is because I've been with
every woman for so long it's it's it's
all pretty much like family so I'm you
know it's it's the best part of the
movie every thought ant-man and with the
Avengers in civil wars so yeah how was
it for you I was especially nice for me
because it was you know was a little bit
like seeing some friends that I met once
long ago and hadn't seen in a while and
I got to come back and hang out and it
was it was amazing I mean it's really
it's it's a fun thing to work on
something that is so kind of global and
has such interest but it's made better
by the fact that everybody is really
cool it was nice to hang out with with
everybody and go to dinner there's some
dinners what an amazing thing to be a
part of the tone on the set this film
has a different tone how was it working
in the fatone who told was it was like a
b-flat I think so yeah it's like a
b-flat which I always I always think
that's the nicest tell ya and it's one
that's really not used very much agreed
agreed
working with the Russo brothers yes tell
us about what they're amazing man
they're awesome
yeah I wish I could do more with them
they're so busy now but yeah they're
it's wonderfully collaborative you know
and super smart and maybe weird kind of
just having one of them around you know
right I know they do you know they they
work in the way that I guess siblings
who have grown up and have been
interested in the same thing their whole
lives they it's like they do share a
brain and you know they're both kind of
in control of everything that's going on
and everything that's going on is so
massive it's still kind of shocking to
me that they're they've got it all going
on yeah rounds they can see it all you
know they're really impressive and for
each of you personally what was the
highway what has been your highlight of
your experience so far in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
it's been what's been the highlight
highlight for you this moment right now
really not not sitting for you you're
pretty amazing and all but I think it's
to determine to this I didn't know this
was happening what was going on it's
it's kind of only now you can kind of
look back and reflect upon the last
decade of all the movies and I got a
people be a part of a lot of those which
is pretty awesome and so I'm very
excited to see this movie get to see it
in my face it's my excited face I can
see it a lot you can't contain him like
it's an incredible thing to be a part I
am late to the game but it is amazing to
be a part of something that is so
beloved all over the world and to pick
out one thing that's been the most
incredible part is impossible it's
pretty great though when you get to hang
out with some kids and when you see kids
react to these characters in these
movies it's a nice it's a nice reminder
of what's the power that it actually has
and what's important the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is a diverse world
how important is it for you guys to play
strong female characters in that um I
you know it's honestly my character has
had such an interesting journey because
I started out in Iron Man 2 as basically
like a glorified secretary who like
kicks ass on the side and then you know
we've got to really like kind of peel
back the layers of an act and build an
actual person um you know not just like
the sexy secretary the sidekick type of
you know played out version of you know
someone so it's it really as the kind of
10 years has passed you know it's it's
amazing to see how important it's been
for you know all these different Studios
to catch up with like what's going on in
the real we're all then what's going on
in the zeitgeist and what's important to
you to fans and audience members and
really it's the it's the audience that
and the fans that have pushed the
studio's like Marvel to
you know to you know come into this
century and you know and to really show
the characters that represent what's
going on in the in this world and so
it's it's really awesome to be to feel a
part of that you know uh yeah I mean it
was it was really cool i when i sat down
with Ryan and he talked to me about this
character Okoye I mean what was really
exciting to me I've always been
passionate about telling stories from an
African female perspective and showing
their complexity as well as their
strength and and and their abilities and
their capabilities and so to hear what
he had in mind was just really thrilling
because it was a character I I just knew
I had never seen before the idea that
she was the head of an army and the head
of the security of this nation and that
the sort of Pat I felt an immediate
connection to that in the sense that you
know having grown up on the continent
like the idea of this sort of nation was
really exciting to me one that had never
been colonized and so the idea of
protecting it it was something I
connected to really quickly and and so
it was it was really cool because I got
to the beauty of that like what scarlet
saying is is we got to really
collaborate and myself and the other
women that we were creating these
characters with with Marvel with Ryan in
the course of creating Black Panther and
and we really got to collaborate on on
our mindsets around how these women
would would address the world and how
they would be you know complicated and
and powerful and they're in a country
that allows that unabashedly brings the
women into the fold as full capable
equal equal members of whatever part of
society they are great at being a part
of so I just loved being able to be a
part of that sort of a narrative and
yeah absolutely it was about time to see
that sort of thing as a whole across
every single genre
you know storytelling and so it's really
exciting but that's happening so much
you know with uh you know with
Scarlett's character and and of course
brie Larson's character and you're just
seeing it in so many ways throughout
things now and that's really exciting
well you guys are both great custodians
in that message two quick questions one
for each of you Scarlett
you've played Black Widow many many many
what's your favorite part about playing
her um I think my favorite part about
playing Black Widow is that she's not
afraid to be vulnerable she really
that's one of her strengths I think is
that she you know she's she doesn't
always know how she's gonna do something
she just knows she's gonna do it and she
doesn't always feel capable she just
she's just gonna try me I'm and and you
know do her best and that's that's you
know that's good enough for her as her
best and I think she's you know someone
who is a very fully realized woman and
and she's grown and she's learned
through her losses and she's kind of
abdun flow with the change and I I like
that about her I like that she's okay
being broken she's okay you know coming
from where she's come from and she's
she's okay with you know having having
these kind of shades of grey in her past
you know I think she's really um she's
she's complicated and she's she's okay
with that I think that's cool and third
time's the charm uh you know she's very
unapologetic and she's not really trying
to please her anybody she really answers
to something much deeper that's you know
really rooted in her for mothers and her
forefathers have created a system that
she believes she must maintain so
there's something really thrilling about
playing a woman who who is unapologetic
in what she can bring to the table and
in her strengths in in how she can
strategize around a situation and and
still at the same time you know has a
ferocity and and is very at ease with
her femininity
you